les leaders réunis au sommet de la paix
en ont plein les bras risque de
récession mondiale inflation et crise
énergétiques à peine rassemblée à
Bangkok un incident vient s'ajouter à la
liste des problèmes
dans une zone maritime contrôlée par le
japonais a dénoncé les tirs répétés de
la Corée du Nord à la bec les États-Unis
ont convoqué une réunion d'urgence
une semaine mouvementée s'achève des
dizaines de missiles russes lancés sur
l'Ukraine en plein sommet du G20
ont tendu avec le président chinois et
au tir de missiles par la Corée du Nord
alors que les régimes autoritaires
semblent chercher la confrontation juste
un Trudeau promet de continuer à passer
ses messages lui qui s'envole pour la
Tunisie où va se dérouler le Sommet de
la Francophonie un autre pays dont le
leader est critiqué pour un recul des
droits démocratiques je vais souligner
mes préoccupations par rapport
recule démocratique qu'on est en train
de voir dans bien des parties du monde
et notre inquiétude avec ce qui se passe
en Tunisie une autre destination une
autre chorégraphie délicate pour Justin
Trudeau toute la semaine le Premier
ministre a cherché à défendre ses
valeurs tout en essayant de trouver de
nouveaux partenaires de danse dans un
monde plombé par des tensions
géopolitiques il est là tout le défi de
la diplomatie trouver l'équilibre entre
fermeté et dialogue ici Louis Blouin
Radio-Canada Bangkok en Thaïlande